i think i've seen different quotes
saying something like we're going
uh forward a matter of years in a matter
of weeks or months because
of kovid what have you seen that maybe
some other folks might have read about
in passing um
in terms of what's happening economy
wide in the labor market
well there i think there are a couple
things happening and there are a couple
reasons behind that acceleration
one is i think the the pandemic
accelerated the demand
for robots software products p
you know factories needed to keep
producing goods even if their employees
were you know didn't want to
be in the factory um you know fedex
tyson the meat processor they lots of
companies have
brought in robots to sort of meet demand
even while their employees
some of them were out sick um and then
you had this the second
reason which was that the actual
technology was just moving forward i
mean we've had
this is a super fast moving area of tech
in the past 18 months we've had
new um advances in robotics i mean the
sort of robot arms that can pick
things and warehouses that's taken a big
step forward
these large language models like gpt3
which are coming out of ai labs and
threatened to replace frankly me
so gbt3 it's like a natural language
ai that can produce simple journalistic
accounts you know people might have seen
it online yeah not even simple
journalistic accounts the guardian
uh wrote an op-ed a few months ago using
gpt-3 and there was a
there was an editor's note at the end of
the article that said
this article was actually easier to edit
than a lot of op-eds that we get from
humans so it's it's getting fairly
sophisticated and then i think the third
thing that the pandemic did was that it
gave
corporate executives cover to do the
kinds of automation that they had wanted
to do for years but had waited on
because they didn't want to be seen as
job killers
so i talked to a number of executives
and consultants who said
you know we could have automated our
call center five years ago
but we didn't want to do that because
you know wouldn't save us that much
money and
it was you know sort of marginal but
also you know people might
our workers might get scared that their
jobs were going away
um but during covid kind of all bets
were off and so a lot of companies
called up their consultants and said hey
let's let's do that automation project
we talked about
well part of it too is there were
consumer preferences where like in the
old days if you had
like the self-driving pizza delivery
vehicle or the
the self-checkout or the cleaning robots
then and you're a customer you're like
oh it's a little bit
uh spooky or or eerie but now you're
like ooh fewer human
uh hands touched my thing like you know
that that's a win
um so i think it gave them cover in
multiple ways
totally yeah so so mckinsey called this
the great acceleration and they said
it's
basically they revised their estimate of
how many
uh workers would be displaced by ai and
automation by the end of the decade and
before the pandemic it was
37 million and now they've changed that
to 45 million
another 8 million jobs thank you
mckinsey for cataloging
our disastrous times where would we be
without mckinsey
telling us how bad it's going to get an
extra 8 million jobs lost
by decades and is enormous
i was struck by what you called
robotic process automation or rpa it's
this very boring acronym
but it turns out it touches a lot a lot
of things and that
companies are like ooh like i i can
invest in these rpa
bots very often um and they just end up
um simplifying processes and saving
money
yeah the the chapter in the book is
called uh beware of boring bots
because i think when we think of
automation and the
the risky kinds of ai we think about you
know skynet
or you know robocop dude i had the same
freaking problem all the time on the
trail i had to constantly be
like look it's not like a robot's gonna
show up to your office
and replace you right it doesn't work
quite like that
right so and and the rpa thing is
fascinating because rpa robotic process
automation is like the most boring part
of the
of the ai industry like it is it is the
least sexy
you know they don't win prizes it's
basically software
programs that can be installed inside
large corporations to do
the work that you know phil in
accounting used to do
um it can you know process invoices and
approve expense reports and
you know plug into databases think
dunder mifflin thank all the people
hanging out in that office exactly
exactly so now if they made the office
in 2021 it would just be like four rpa
bots um talking to each other
but i i was fascinated by this because i
didn't basically know it existed and i
started going to all these conferences
and talking to all these executives in
the rpa market
and they are really blunt um
about the fact that this technology is
replacing people
i mean there was one thing that was
called like the boomer remover which is
so dark
i mean i shouldn't laugh because it was
literally it's like hey we can replace
an elderly worker yeah this was a guy i
met at a cocktail party in san francisco
and he came up to me and
introduced himself when he said you know
i've got this ai software called the
boomer remover
and uh it basically lets companies
replace sort of middle managers
um and he was very proud of that and i
was thinking to myself like this is
going to be a total
disaster i had sort of the same feeling
that i you know i'm
i'm guessing you had early in your your
sort of conversion on this stuff where
it's like
oh man if there's one of these people
selling boomer remover software there's
got to be thousands of them
and this is happening all over the
economy and and what are we going to do
about it
yeah i mean one of the moments for me
was talking to a very high-end venture
capitalist based in boston who was like
yeah
about two-thirds of the stuff i'm seeing
is is going to
um get rid of significant numbers of
jobs and i was like
well you're literally someone who's just
staring at
uh the system and it made sense to me
too intuitively that
the low-hanging fruit for a lot of tech
companies is going to be saving labor
costs because you have to try and show
where your financial returns are going
to come from and imagining that
all of the financial returns are going
to come from these you know blue sky
i mean it made much more sense to me
that you could
replace phil and then there are a
million fills
and that's enough to grow some very very
significant companies
um so we all had our moments kevin uh
and um i just want to dig into something
you just said which is interesting so
you're a new york times tech reporter
and you go to conferences um like how
does that work are you like hey i want
to go to this conference
[Laughter]
and then when you get there are you
media like like that people react to you
like they're just pitching you
stuff because they want publicity for
their company it works a lot of ways i
mean this was
pre-coveted obviously when there
actually were conferences now i just
show up on zoom
um but pre-covered you know i would go
because i was covering it or there was a
talk i wanted to hear or i was on a
panel or speaking
um but conferences are where a lot of
this stuff happens um
at least where it's announced and so um
you know there's a scene
in the uh in the book where i i went to
davos which is like i don't know if you
have you ever been to davos i have not
been to davos
kevin tell us more it is seemed like a
trip
so davos is like the i call it the
coachella of capitalism it's like this
you know week-long retreat in the swiss
alps where all these ceos and
billionaires and heads of state get
together
and you know people celebrities go and
they fly their private jets in it's like
the biggest most
gaudy um you know conference that
basically ever
has existed and um i was i've only been
the one time this was in
in 2019 but i the thing that i was
struck by was how
different the um the conversations that
i heard were that were on the record and
off the record
so like during the day how davos means
the masters of the universe don't sound
exactly the same when a microphone is on
and when they're at the bar kevin no it
was like a total 180 and maybe i'm naive
because i was just shocked but like
during the day they would have all these
panels
and they would talk about you know oh
we're doing human-centered automation to
you know free up workers and bring in
you know prosperity and this is going to
be great for everyone
and then at night i would like go to
these dinners and i would sit next to
you know the ceo of some fortune 500
company
and he'd be like grilling the guy next
to him who you know worked at some tech
company about like how can i get rid of
my back office um and it was really
stark
and really frightening how eager the
corporate executives were
to just get rid of as many people as
possible and like the
that you know this but the classic
comeback the classic thing that people
say is well you know technology has
always
gotten rid of jobs but it always creates
more jobs
and so i started looking at that and and
found that that that really
the evidence for that just really isn't
there this time so lazy man it
infuriated me again people are supposed
to be pretty pretty analytical would
just bust [ __ ] out on me and i'd be like
look if someone walked into your office
um and busted out 120 year old fact
pattern on you you'd like throw them out
you'd be like well i've got some like
you know i've got like a buggy whipped
case study
[Laughter]
you'll be like oh i should invest for
sure like the whole thing just struck me
as so
self-serving and ridiculous and lazy you
could ratchet like i did get that
an awful lot um that's quite dark
that the but not surprising to me again
that the conversations in private were
so
different from the panels give us some
more davos
dirt uh kevin it'll be fun oh my god
yeah it's hilarious so i was i was there
as a journalist
and the way that davos works is there's
like a it's like a hierarchy of badge
colors
so like if you are like a like a inner
circle like
super elite um you get like one
i forget which color it is it's like a
pink badge or something like a gold
badge or something and then there's sort
of
six or seven tiers below that and i was
like you know
press is like the lowest tier and so
there are a lot of things that you know
you just can't get into as a journalist
um but there are some things that you
can get into and so i i managed to
weasel my way into some
some pretty funny uh events but it's
basically it's this whole sort of
do-gooder ethos
and you know everyone there is you know
interested in humanitarian pursuits and
philanthropy
and like it's sort of um that's the
davos that you see and then the one that
you don't see is like everyone just
getting like drunk at night and you know
gossiping and
hanging out with celebrities and uh it's
sort of a big party
[Music]
you